[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRIAN KEMLER: Good afternoon.
Is everybody ready for the
best accessibility I/O ever?
Woo!
Right on, right on.
My name is Brian Kemler.
I'm a PM on Android
Accessibility.
Our goal is to ensure that
everyone can use our products
no matter what their ability.
Specifically, we design and
build Accessibility Suite,
Sound Amplifier, Live
Transcribe, and now Live
Caption.
We've invested heavily
in the last year
to make audio on Android
much more accessible.
So we'll be focusing
a lot on that today.
Here with me today
are Melissa, Lauren,
and Kelly, our passionate team
of researchers, programmers,
and engineers.
Today, I'm going to share my
perspective on accessibility's
mission and why it matters.
I'll discuss new products for
the deaf and hard of hearing.
Melissa will show you how
we use structured research
to inform our most important
product-making decisions.
Lastly, Kelly and
Lauren are going
to talk about new
products for users
with physical disabilities,
reduced dexterity, low vision,
and blindness.
So now let's talk
about our mission.
Accessibility's mission
is integral to Google's.
So integral it's in the
mission statement itself--
to make the world's
information universally
accessible and useful.
Let's unpack that a little bit.
Universally accessible means
everyone can use Android.
We don't expect users to
adapt to our products.
Rather, we adapt our
products to our users
because we think of
accessibility as a human right.
If there are
barriers for anyone,
we have more work to do.
And it's with this mantra
that we design, build,
and apply Google magic
to make both our products
and the real world
around us more successful
and more useful for more
users in more situations.
The world's information
means it's not just
about making what's on
the device accessible,
but it's about making the
planet more accessible.
And to do this, we apply
advances in machine learning
and artificial intelligence--
what I call the Google magic--
to meet the needs of
underserved communities.
Last February, we
launched Live Transcribe,
an accessibility-first
experience enabling--
[MIC FEEDBACK]
--anyone to have a
conversation without feedback.
Allowing anyone to
have a conversation,
even if they can't hear.
You can think of Live
Transcribe as captioning
for the real world.
Sound Amplifier and
Lookout are also
great examples of building
accessibility-first
experiences.
And you could think of
this overall approach
as a practical,
useful, and potentially
transformative application
of augmented reality.
So why is this important?
Why do we care?
Many of us, in fact, including
myself at one point in time,
believe that disability was
something that only affected
a small set of the population.
Even in the strictest
sense, that set is massive.
It's a billion people, or 15%
of the world's population.
But let's start to
think about disability
a little more holistically.
So if we include people
who don't self-identify
as having a disability,
this number-- one billion--
it doubles.
It grows.
If we think of friends,
family, and loved
ones of folks who
have disabilities,
well, then that
number grows again.
And thinking of this
even more expansively,
if we think about
disability to include people
with temporary conditions, like
a broken arm or a broken leg,
or situational ones like
driving and texting--
don't do it-- then
our circle expands
to include nearly
the entire planet.
So it's really
everyone's work to make
not just our products, but
the planet, more accessible.
And when we do so, we're
affirming that accessibility
is a human right.
So apart from doing
the right thing,
I'm going to talk to you a
little bit today about why
there are some very positive
karmic consequences when we
design for accessibility first.
So much so, a term
is coined for it,
and that term is
the curb cut effect.
So you see, back in the day,
there were no curb cuts,
just as at one point in time,
there were no closed captions.
So that meant that people who
use wheelchairs effectively
encountered a wall every
time they came to a curb.
So in 1945, there was a guy
in Kalamazoo, Michigan, named
Jeff Fisher, who is disabled.
And he advocated and
fought for the installation
of the country's first curb cut,
and they caught on globally.
Sidewalks, and more
importantly, cities,
became independently navigable
for the very first time.
And this had
positive consequences
literally for everyone.
For parents, with
kids in strollers,
for people toting
luggage, for workers
with dollies or hand trucks.
And now today, we can't even
imagine a world without them,
because we're much safer and
it's much easier to get along--
to get around.
And this is what was
dubbed the curb cut effect.
Another realization of the curb
cut effect is closed captions.
Personally, I love captions.
They're great for the World
Series or the World Cup
at a loud bar.
They let me listen in
silence when I'm on the train
or at the library, or I don't
want to bother my co-workers.
As awesome as they
are for me, they're
game-changing for the 466
million people on the planet
who have hearing loss.
So about a year ago,
we prototyped and built
an accessibility-first
application
called Live Transcribe, and
we launched it in February.
I'm going to switch over
and do a little demo of Live
Transcribe.
Demo-- yep, great.
So this is nothing special.
This is a basic Android
smartphone, as you can tell.
I'm just speaking
naturally and quickly,
and it's picking
everything up in real time.
It works in over 70 languages.
And it's a great tool
or a great bridge
to carry around with
you in your inner pocket
if you need to transcribe
a conversation.
It's amazing.
It also captures
very subtle nuances.
So I can say something such
as I bought a new jersey
in New Jersey, and--
it doesn't work for the
demo, but I usually say it,
and I usually say that I bought
a new jersey in New Jersey.
Well, it doesn't like it.
It usually gets context,
but the demo gods
are not forgiving today.
It also has a great feature,
which we call type back.
So if you prefer not to speak,
or in case you can't speak,
you can type a response
back to the person speaking
right here in the interface.
So it's really more of a
two-way conversation tool
than it is strictly captions.
Awesome.
My demo didn't work.
Back to the slides, please.
So now that we literally have
captions in the real world,
what's the next
frontier for captions?
So I'm super glad you asked.
Let's turn to the
growth of online video
and build empathy for
people who are missing out
on this explosion of content.
So every minute,
400 hours of video
are being uploaded to YouTube.
So we saw that
this is a problem,
and in 2009, we added automated
captions to all the content
on YouTube, which was an
awesome, awesome first start.
But what about personal
videos, social media, podcasts?
You know, the stuff that we
love to use each and every day.
They're typically uncaptioned,
meaning for the deaf and hard
of hearing, it's
effectively a silent movie.
So led by the creative lab
in New York who is here
today, we started exploring
a simple question--
could we automatically
caption any media playing
across your phone?
So together with a
whole bunch of teams
from Mountain View and New
York and Tel Aviv and speech
research, and the creative
lab, and audio framework
and accessibility,
we banded together
and we spent a year trying
to solve this problem.
And so I'm going
to let the result,
Live Caption, speak for itself
and switch over to the demo.
So I'm using Google Photos, and
this is nothing special here.
It's a video of my cat and my
fiancee, and a little message
that they recorded for me.
SPEAKER 1: Hi, honey.
Hope you're having a great time
at I/O. We miss you so much.
[? Tico ?] misses you.
Hope you're having a great time.
BRIAN KEMLER: So you can
see, I can caption anything
on the device, and it went away.
Let me bring it back.
SPEAKER 1: Hi, honey.
Hope you're having a great time
at I/O. We miss you so much.
[? Tico ?] misses you.
Hope you're having a great time.
Hi, honey.
Hope you're having a great
time at I/O. We miss--
BRIAN KEMLER: So
that's Live Caption.
And it works with
podcasts, it works
with videos that you record,
voicemail, or instant messaging
apps on video and so forth.
And we're super excited.
You may have seen that we
mentioned it in the keynotes
today.
What you see there is literally
just the tip of the iceberg.
So we use recurrent
neural networks
that we've shrunk down from
these monster models that
used to run in the cloud, and we
run them locally on the device,
and that gives us some
really cool advantages.
So one, it lets the
product work offline.
So I can be in a
totally offline mode.
I can be in a plane.
It's going to work.
Two, audio never
goes up to the cloud.
So it just sits there locally.
And best of all, developers
and content providers
never need to lift a finger.
If there's audio,
there are captions.
So with Live Caption, every
app, billions of videos,
and podcasts from any
source are one step
closer to being universally
accessible on Android.
Now over to Melissa to talk
about how we use research
to inform our most important
product-making decisions.
MELISSA BARNHART:
Thank you, Brian.
[APPLAUSE]
Hi, everyone.
My name is Melissa Barnhart,
and I'm a researcher on Android.
And today, I'd like to talk to
you about the user experience.
So when you think about
the user experience,
I'd like you to
think about empathy.
Empathy is at the
heart of design.
Without the
understanding of what
others see, feel,
and experience,
design is a pointless task.
And to be empathetic
technologists,
we have to set aside
our own assumptions
and consider other perspectives.
Now, a great way
to build empathy
is through user research.
User research focuses on
understanding behaviors
and needs through a
variety of methodologies
like interviews, observations,
or survey, just to name a few.
Like a compass,
user research can
help point you and your
product in the right direction.
And you can utilize
user research
at any stage in your design
and development process.
Before you begin
building, user research
can uncover unmet needs
and inspire designs
that actually meet those needs.
The number one reason
for startup failure
is lack of market
need for a product,
but you can minimize this
risk by conducting research
before development even begins.
And when development
is underway,
user research can help you
evaluate different design
solutions and ensure that your
user experience stays on track.
And then when your product
is out in the market,
you can use research
to help measure
the impact of your designs
and also to show the ROI.
So today, I'd like to share
an example of how we've
used user research to improve
Live Transcribe, a new Android
application that provides
real-time transcription
for the deaf and
hard of hearing.
A team of research
scientists at Google
identified a new opportunity
for automatic speech recognition
and built the first prototype
for Live Transcribe.
So we have the technology, but
what about the user experience?
We had a lot of questions
about Live Transcribe
that we hoped to address through
research with the deaf and hard
of hearing participants.
For example, what are
their first impressions
of Live Transcribe?
Also, how would they
expect scrolling
to work in both landscape
and portrait orientations?
Should it scroll
from top to bottom,
should it kind of fade
away, or should it
resemble a physical book?
But our most pressing question
was about the visual design.
What font style, type form,
text size, text color,
and background color
should we default to?
We assumed that users
would want to see
differently-colored
confidence levels to indicate
the accuracy of
the transcription,
but we didn't know for sure.
And good research starts
with good research questions
like these ones.
So to answer our
research questions,
we took a mixed
methods approach.
We started with a usability
study in a Google lab
to evaluate our
minimum viable product
with people who had moderate
to profound hearing loss.
But we also wanted to
know how people would
use Live Transcribe over time.
How would it work in different
environments like in the home
or in the classroom,
and would people's needs
change with continued use?
So to answer these
questions, we partnered
with Gallaudet University,
the world's premier university
for the deaf and
hard of hearing.
And that collaboration
allowed us
to collect longitudinal feedback
from faculty and students
who used Live Transcribe
in everyday life.
And after iterating on our
designs based on their feedback
and adding new
functionality, we conducted
a second lab-based
usability study again
with participants who had
moderate to profound hearing
loss.
OK, so let's dig into those
lab studies a little bit.
Our protocols started
with questions
like tell me about a time when
you use real time captioning?
What did you like
about the experience
and what did you dislike
about the experience?
So background
questions helped us
understand previous experiences
as well as current needs.
Then we enabled the
prototype, and we handed it
to the participant.
And for the next 60 minutes,
we initiated conversation
about a variety of topics
and generally observed
how the participants
interacted with the phone.
We also evaluated
different text flows
and probed for feedback
on the visual design.
So in our prototype,
white italicized text
signified unfinalized text
whereas yellow normal text
represented finalized text.
Did these participants
understand that color and type
form indicated confidence
in the transcription,
and was that information
even valuable?
So it was in this
research that we
learned that changing the
type form and text color
actually distracted participants
from the conversation.
Additionally, our
participants self-reported
that italics made reading
more difficult for them,
and these insights
were reinforced
by previous research
in this space which
says that a transcript is
easiest to read when it's not
layered with these
extra signals.
We also learned that our
original scrolling text
flow felt natural, unlike
the other flows that we
showed participants.
It didn't force them
to shift their eyes
to another part of the screen.
So because of these
insights, we removed
those colorful
confidence levels.
We used a normal type forum
instead of an italic type form.
And we proceeded with
the scrolling text flow.
And this is just the beginning.
We'll continue to
make improvements
as we conduct further research.
But what I really hope to show
today is the power of empathy.
So by putting aside
our own assumptions
about the visual design
and conducting research
with our target audience, we
changed the product design
to be more legible and
ultimately accessible.
And next up is Lauren here to
talk to us about dexterity.
[APPLAUSE]
LAUREN WINSTON: Thanks, Melissa.
Hi, everyone.
My name's Lauren, and
I'm a software engineer
on central accessibility.
Now let's talk a little
bit about dexterity,
the challenges users with
dexterity impairment face,
and the services on Android
to help with these challenges.
According to the US census,
more than 50 million people,
or more than 19% of
the US population,
has some form of
mobility impairment.
Moreso in the US, more than
two million of these people
have an impairment that
impacts how understandable
their speech is.
Over 50 million people
have limited dexterity
in their hands, and
nearly 20 million people
have difficulty
lifting and grasping.
The majority of this population
is over 65 years old.
Those with severe
dexterity challenges
include those with conditions
such as ALS, cerebral palsy,
Parkinson's, or
spinal cord injuries.
Some conditions result
in users experiencing
involuntary movements such
as spasms and tremors.
They may also have
difficulties with speech
and having their
speech understood.
Many conditions impacting
dexterity are progressive.
As loss of dexterity happens,
fine motor skills may regress.
People might have difficulty
with picking things up
or maintaining a hold on items.
Grasping or interacting
with a phone
can be particularly
challenging for people
within this population.
There are varying
levels of severity
of dexterity impairments, and we
offer various apps and services
on Android that can be
used to help users based
on their own individual needs.
We introduced Accessibility
Menu last year
designed to make common
interactions easier for people
with dexterity challenges.
Accessibility Menu simplifies
common actions such as power
off, locking the
screen, and accessing
notifications in recent apps.
When enabled, it can
be opened via a button
at the bottom of
the screen, which
helps those with limited reach.
Now we're adding new controls
for volume and brightness
so the user can continuously
adjust volume and brightness
without leaving the menu.
We've also added an option
for large buttons and settings
to make the menu buttons larger.
So those that may have
more limited hand dexterity
can use Voice Access to
control their phone via voice.
Voice Access uses voice
commands to perform gestures
on elements on the
screen without needing
to physically touch the phone.
Voice Access was
recently launched
in September of last year.
You can download it now
at g.co/voiceaccess.
Voice Access places
an overlay of numbers
over the actionable
elements on a screen.
Simply speak to your phone
with actions such as "click 7"
or "go back" to interact
with your phone.
When Voice Access
is enabled, you
can continue using your
usual Google Assistant
commands, such as setting a
timer or checking the weather.
A feedback bar is always present
at the top of the screen that
captures your spoken phrases.
You can specifically
refer to elements
by their number
such as "top seven"
or you can refer to the
name of the elements.
So if you wanted to
open an app, like you
wanted to open Google Keep,
you could say "open Keep."
We're also happy to announce
that we brought support
to French, Italian,
German, and Spanish.
So Voice Access
is great for those
with limited hand dexterity
and understandable speech.
But there's many out
there who may not
be able to speak clearly.
For those Android users
we have Switch Access.
Switch Access allows users
with limited hand dexterity
and limited speech to navigate
through their phone using
external buttons or switches.
I'll show you what a typical
switch might look like.
So a typical switch
could look something
like this with
two large buttons,
and a user can interact with
the switch with their hands,
or if they have more control
on other parts of their body,
they may use another
part of their bodies,
such as their feet.
In a common two-switch
case, one switch
can be likened to a Tab
that moves the highlight
on the screen when pressed,
while a second switch can
be thought of as an Enter that
selects the highlighted item
when pressed.
Switches can be configured
to meet user needs,
and switch access can be used
with as little as one switch.
Most input devices work with
Switch Access, including
just a regular USB keyboard.
So text editing is commonly a
pain point for switch users.
So we recently added
text-editing menus.
These menus add shortcuts for
previously time-consuming text
editing tasks, such as
highlighting and deleting
text, undoing or redoing
actions, copy, cut, and paste.
This allows text editing to
be done much more quickly,
and with the use of as
little as one switch.
I'll show a quick demo of this.
OK, so in this demo,
I'm using switches
configured to the volume keys.
Assigning switches
to the volume keys
is a very easy
way for developers
to test out Switch
Access on their own apps
without needing to have
an external switch.
So using the volume
keys, I'm going
to go through the
elements on the screen
until I get to the text
field I wish to edit.
I can select the text field,
and it brings up our text menu.
So I want to move a word around.
So I will go to highlight and
then choose the granularity
that I wish to highlight.
So I'll choose Highlight
Previous Word, which highlights
this word "peaches" here.
Then I can cut the
word with the menu.
And then now I want to paste
the words somewhere else.
So to do this, I first
need to move the cursor.
So I can go to
Previous, and then I'll
do previous line to move to the
beginning of this text field,
and then I can place
the word there.
But what if I made a mistake?
We have undo and redo
actions added to these menus.
Text-editing mistakes can be
very costly for switch users,
so these actions allow our
users to go more quickly
back to text editing.
And now I'll go
back to the slides.
OK, so switching gears,
let's talk a little bit
about what's new for vision.
To start with,
here's a little bit
of background on
this population.
According to the World
Health Organization,
it's estimated that 253
million people globally
live with moderate to
severe visual impairment,
and people over 50
are most at risk.
36 million of these
people are blind.
We're here to help
people within vision loss
be able to access and enjoy
not just their phones,
but the world around them.
Lookout is an Android
app that helps
make the real world
accessible for people
who are blind or low vision
by helping them complete tasks
and routines more independently.
We launched Lookout
in March of this year.
Now I'll show a quick
video that speaks
a little more to
what Lookout does
and how it's used by our users.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
All right.
[APPLAUSE]
So as you saw in
that video, Lookout
is able to detect and recognize
a variety of objects including
currency and text through
computer vision and machine
learning.
Lookout uses several
image classifiers that
run continuously on the device.
This allows Lookout to process
video and provide results
to users in near real time.
Since information is
processed on device,
Lookout can even work
in airplane mode.
Results are also scored based on
a variety of signals, including
user context.
Our goal is to provide
the most relevant results
to users in a timely manner.
Lookout contains three modes--
explore, shopping,
and quick read.
It allows users to further
contextualize their environment
and what kind of information
they want out of it.
Explore is the most
widespread mode
that can be used for a
variety of daily routines,
such as cleaning the house,
cooking dinner, or visiting
a new space for the first time.
Shopping includes on-device
barcode lookup as well as
currency detection.
Quick read focuses
on text, and can
be used for activities such
as going through the mail
or reading labels on
items in the kitchen.
Here's a quote from
one of our users.
"I used Lookout
once in preparation
for making spaghetti.
It very accurately
describes each item
without me having to maneuver
the device or struggle
to get the items in focus."
Finding the correct
ingredients to use
when cooking is something
that many sighted users hardly
think about.
This shows how Lookout can be
used to really change lives
by helping people who
are blind or low vision
be more independent.
You can find look out on
Google Play at g.co/lookoutapp.
It's available in the
US and it was initially
launched on Pixel.
And we're happy to
announce that Lookout
is expanding to Samsung S8
through S10 and LG G7 and G8
devices.
Support on these new
devices is rolling out now.
We want to get Lookout in
the hands of as many users as
possible, so we anticipate
releasing Lookout on more
devices throughout the year.
Now I'll hand it off to Kelly
to talk a little bit more
about what else
is new in vision.
[APPLAUSE]
KELLY CHEN: Hello, everyone.
My name is Kelly Chen.
I'm the program manager
from Google Pixel team
and based in Taiwan.
Let's figure out
how to make a phone
accessible for blind
and near-vision users.
TalkBack is Android's
screen reader.
We provide a spoken
feedback so that who
are blind or have
difficulty seeing,
they can use their phone
without looking at a screen.
TalkBack can read as on screen
reader loudly, and then users
to interact with their
devices by gestures.
Before we jump into
the new feature,
I want you to think
about something.
What will you do to
find movie details?
Like what kind of movie
starts at the cinema?
You can navigate it
easily on your phone,
and it's simple for you.
Now imagine that
how difficult this
would be if you couldn't
see on the screen?
Not so easy, right?
Today, we are going
to give everyone
a better user journey
in your screen reader
to have you find--
you navigate and find
your content quickly.
People who cannot see well,
they need to swipe one element
at a time to let a screen
reader read it for them.
And if you want to
find the things,
they may need to do
a lot of gestures.
That's why we enhance the
screen search feature.
So we provide a user interface
to perform the search.
And the [INAUDIBLE]
can be triggered
by not only keyboard shortcuts,
but also by touch gestures
and voice input.
[INAUDIBLE],, it provides any
languages supported by Android,
and it's always available you.
You can use it in
Accessibility Suite 7.3 now.
OK, let's go to the live demo.
OK, let's say you are
curious that [INAUDIBLE]..
So you want to learn more.
So let's see how this works
in TalkBack without search.
[DING]
SPEAKER 2: TalkBack on.
Chrome.
KELLY CHEN: And just listen--
how many steps I'm doing.
SPEAKER 2: Connection is--
HD-- one open-- more options--
products and features--
Google logo--
collapse-- open
the-- accessibility--
products and feature--
explore some of-- products--
resources-- accessibility--
accessibility-- get
started with the--
Android OS-- from hearing aid--
Android access--
Switch Access help--
link, double-tap to activate.
KELLY CHEN: See, it takes
like 10 or 20 swipes.
And you can imagine, like,
if a link at the bottom,
so we may need to swipe
more than 30 or 40 times.
Now with search feature,
it becomes super easy.
Let's try it.
So to start search,
swipe left then down.
SPEAKER 2: Android OS.
Type search term.
Showing English US
QWERTY keyboard.
KELLY CHEN: OK.
SPEAKER 2: Research-- editing--
type search term-- edit box.
KELLY CHEN: So it will
bring you to a search page,
then [INAUDIBLE] switch.
But you may wonder how
people with limited
eyesight how they do it,
but it's the same behavior.
You just touch it on a keyboard.
If you listen, [INAUDIBLE]
what do you want [INAUDIBLE],,
you just lift your finger
up, then it will work.
So let's do it.
SPEAKER 2:
S-S-W-5-5-T selected--
switch-- C-H-- two matches.
KELLY CHEN: And a list with
matches will be showing.
And then you can check which
one you are looking for,
then double-click it.
It will bring you
to the details.
Then see the first ones to which
[INAUDIBLE] is exactly what
you want, and then you go it.
SPEAKER 2: Clear and--
Switch Access--
Switch Access help--
link-- Chrome-- get started
with Accessibility Scanner.
KELLY CHEN: OK.
SPEAKER 2: Double-tap
to activate.
KELLY CHEN: It's that simple.
So we-- the [INAUDIBLE]
will get the user to a place
faster, and to make people more
productive, and efficiency.
OK, I'd like to go
back to our slide.
Dark Theme-- this is one
of my favorite features.
You know why?
Because when I'm in bed using my
phone in low-light conditions,
and I believe a lot of you may
have this kind of experience.
And it may be easier for you
use your phone, like read it
and browse the phone easily.
And it's even helpful for people
who are sensitive to light
or they have low vision.
So it's as if it
were a Dark Theme.
And you can find the
options under Settings,
and then you can find it on
accessibility and the display.
It's coming on Android Q, and
it also saves your battery life.
Now, let's talk about
not of just vision,
but all kinds of disabilities.
Let's try if you want
to change your volume.
So you can look at
your volume button,
and there's the right
side of the screenshot,
you can see that
there's a control panel.
So either way, it'll show
only for a few seconds,
and you imagine if people
with physical impairments
or limited sight, they may
not get enough time to do it.
So that, Accessibility
Timeouts, it's
a new feature which give
us a little extra time
to interact with the devices.
We help people to find
a way, and then you
can change the time on the
accessibility settings.
So it make people to
do it more efficient.
What app developer
would need to do
is to use the
Accessibility Manager
API to get a
[INAUDIBLE] timeout,
and to follow the value
[INAUDIBLE] works.
And this is also
coming in Android Q.
We will have these
five sections tomorrow,
so you're all
welcome to join us.
So let's hand it over to
Brian for the summary.
Thank you.
BRIAN KEMLER: Thank you.
Thank you, Kelly.
Thank you, Melissa.
Thank you, Lauren.
Thank you, creative lab.
Today, we talked
about our mission
of making our products
and the real world
more universally accessible.
We dove into the curb cut effect
to drive home how important
and what the wonderful
unintended consequences
of building for
accessibility can be.
I spoke a little
bit about Android,
and how now with
our smartphone, you
are able to caption both the
real world and almost all
of the content on the device.
No other operating system in
the world can make that claim.
Melissa did a wonderful job at
describing and demonstrating
the before and after of
how we use her research
to inform our decisions and
really upend our own biases
and make informed
decisions based on data.
Lauren demonstrated
Voice Access and Switch
Access that innovate a way
to use a two-button keyboard.
I think that is so cool that you
can text edit with two buttons.
It's just awesome.
Kelly talked about
TalkBack, Dark Theme,
and all of these
wonderful new products
that we have for vision.
So I'm not going to keep
you guys any longer,
but I want to let you know
about a couple of other talks,
including one today
that we're going
to do on accessible audio on
Android at 5:00 PM on Stage 7.
So if you want to dive
in on the audio topic,
we'll be talking
about audiograms.
It's going to be really cool.
We'll do a hearing
loss simulation.
Tomorrow we're
going to have a talk
on demystifying accessibility
development on Android.
That's targeted
toward developers.
And then lastly, we have
two accessibility-related
experiments tents.
One the experiments sandbox,
and the other the accessibility
sandbox.
So everybody, thank you
so much for coming today.
Thank you for your
interest in accessibility,
and we hope you
have a blast at I/O.
[MUSIC PLAYING]